Why Sideburns are Called That
Have you ever wondered why sideburns are called
that?
Well, wonder no more:
It turns out, despite this particular brand
of facial hair style being around as far back
as at least 100 BC (with one of the earliest
known instances being in a mosaic of Alexander
the Great), sideburns were named after a specific
man in the late 19th century.
The man was politician, businessman, and Union
Army General, Ambrose Burnside.
Burnside sported a slightly unusual facial
hair style with particularly prominent “mutton
chop” sideburns connected to a moustache,
while keeping his chin shaved perfectly clean.
Burnside was an extremely poor General, something
he himself was well aware of.
For instance, because of his own ineptitude
as a military commander, he twice refused
to take command of the Army of the Potomac
before ultimately giving in and accepting.
Nevertheless, Burnside’s popularity as a
General and later politician, in combination
with the fairly unique formation of his whiskers,
helped start something of a new facial hair
trend.
Around the 1870s-1880s, this gave rise to
this facial hair style being named “burnsides”.
Within a few years of this, the facial hair
down the side of one’s cheeks, rather than
being called “mutton chops” as it was
at the time in some regions, began being called
a modification of “burnsides”- “sideburns”,
with the first documented instance of this
being in 1887.
Presumably the shift was from the fact that
this part of the “burnsides” facial hair
style was on the sides of the face- and of
course, leaving the “burns” part in in
homage to the aforementioned style.
Shortly after “sideburns” popped up, an
alternate “sideboards” also made its debut,
with “boards” thought to have been shortened
from “border”, so essentially “side-boarder”,
which is a fitting description of the style.
Bonus Facts:
• An old 19th century slang term for a man
who liked to frequent brothels was “beard-splitter”,
presumably coming from the fact that people
used to commonly refer to not just a certain
style of facial hair, but other bushy hair
as well, as a beard (starting around the 17th
century).
• Mutton chops, besides being a slab of
rib meat cut somewhat perpendicular to the
spine, also refers to a style of sideburn
where the facial hair tends to grow larger
as it extends down towards the chin, with
the chin then being shaved.
The first known instance of this style of
sideburn being named such was around the mid-1860s
and is presumed to have been called this due
to the shape somewhat resembling the mutton
chop cut of meat.
The meat itself was first called such in the
early 18th century.
• Although examples can be seen all over
the map throughout recorded history, sideburns
weren’t a terribly popular form of facial
hair until around the early 19th century,
particularly being popular then in Western
Europe among members of the military.
From here, the style began to spread throughout
the world.
Sideburns declined in popularity in the early
20th century, but saw a resurgence with a
much more conservative version of them popping
back up in the mid-20th century thanks to
the likes of James Dean and Elvis Presley.
This new version tended to be shaved close
to the face, rather than the formerly common
mutton-chop version.
In stark contrast to sideburns in the 19th
century, most often worn by respected military-men,
sideburns post-1950s began being seen as a
facial hair style of rebels.
• The English word “moustache” comes
from the French word of the same spelling,
“moustache”, and popped up in English
around the 16th century.
The French word in turn comes from the Italian
word “mostaccio”, from the Medieval Latin
“mustacium” and in turn the Medieval Greek
“moustakion”.
We now finally get to the earliest known origin
which was from the Hellenistic Greek “mustax”,
meaning “upper lip”, which may or may
not have come from the Hellenistic Greek “mullon”,
meaning “lip”.
It is theorized that this in turn came from
the Proto-Indo-European root “*mendh-“,
meaning “to chew” (which is also where
we get the word “mandible”).
• The longest moustache ever recorded was
in Italy on March 4, 2010, and measured in
at 14 ft. long (4.29 m).
The proud owner of that magnificent moustache
was Indian Ram Singh Chauhan.